bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 28
septembre merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal on commence
avec le sommaire de votre actualité
locale
une première samedi soir la messe a été
célébrée en arabe à l'église
saint-pierre du lac de montigny le
bretonneux et ce sera dorénavant le cas
une fois par mois
l'actualité récente autour des migrants
et des chrétiens d'orient a incité les
responsables du diocèse à instaurer si
ce rendez-vous kangoo trafic les
différents utilitaires de la marque au
losange sont tous passés par ici sur le
site de villiers saint frédéric
sita qui vient de fêter ses 50 ans et
puis en culture rencontre avec le
pianiste chat sol qui vient de se
produire sur la scène du théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
concerts donnés dans le cadre du
festival de musique d'ile-de-france et
en plateau avec nous ce soir ludovic que
ça vaut du comité catholique contre la
faim et pour le développement terre
solidaire et christine bouvet de la
paroisse de montigny le bretonneux mon
soir à vous deux mrc est devenu centre
au plateau nous parlerons de votre
actualité dans quelques instants
c'était une promesse de campagne du
nouveau maire philippe benassaya ce
matin le maire le maire de bois d'arcy a
inauguré les locaux de la police
municipale
la brigade compte à présent quatre
agents budget de ce projet 45000 euros
un centre de visualisation et de la
vidéoprotection également été installé
quatre caméras sont actuellement
utilisés douze autres seront bientôt
active
un dispositif financé entièrement par
versailles grand parc
écoutez les précisions du maire philippe
benassaya au micro d' elodie moines non
il n'avait pas avant il y avait une
sorte de tabous idéologiques sur la sur
la police municipale à bord qu'on arrive
pourquoi une police municipale d'abord
parce que l'état nous demande de plus en
plus
de nous organiser il se désengage de
plus en plus et nous on doit s'organiser
le commissariat de fontenay s'est
éloigné pour nous puisque maintenant
c'est le commissaire plaisir le
commissaire de fontenay devenir poste de
police l'insécurité présenta les pas
catastrophique sur bercy loin de là mais
en matière de sécurité il faut prévenir
et puis c'est la création d'un service
public supplémentaire et en temps de
crise offrir un service de proximité
plus aux arcisien c'est quand même un
plus nous avons créé cette ce service de
manière très très lisse progressif on
n'a pas fait ça on n'a qu'un seul coup
pour ne pas mettre en danger nos
finances locales et je vous disais il ya
quelques instants en titre nous allons
parler religion
à présent nous sommes plateau avec les
deux invités ludovic salle d'eau et que
cing vous avez vous organisé en octobre
trois conférences sur trois semaines
pour cerner le thème de l'environnement
et des enjeux écologiques planétaires à
partir de l'encyclique du pape françois
laudato six métiers dits médiatisé sous
le nom d' encyclique sur l'écologie vous
souhaitez profiter du retentissement de
cet événement pour un fou pour
approfondir la réflexion des chrétiens
absolument c'est tout à fait le but que
nous nous sommes fixés de d'essayer de
donner trois éclairages grâce à trois
intervenants un petit peu spécialisés
dans leur domaine pour mieux prendre en
compte ce texte qui est très important
très fédérateur très courageux alors
justement ce que vous pouvez vous me
rappelez peut-être illégalement quelques
mots quel et voilà sur quoi portent ce
texte pour ceux qui ne sont pas au
courant
et bien ce texte était très intéressant
parce qu'il lit de façon forte là
l'écologie et la justice sociale c'est à
dire que l'un ne va pas sans l'autre
justice sociale écologie éthique et
spiritualité et ça c'est un jeu de très
forts dans ce que dit françois est un
leitmotiv qui revient assez souvent
c'est que tout est lié
effectivement tout est lié notamment je
pense à l'écologie c'est vraiment voilà
il faut pousser les chrétiens à
réfléchir sur ce thème c'est important
les chrétiens ne fléchissaient déjà sur
ce thème le l'intérêt de ce nouveau
texte qui justement
nous pousse à agir le pape nous dit
c'est fini maintenant revenons à la
source de l'évangile et avec la source
de l'évangile comprenons que prendre en
compte le monde et prendre en compte le
plus pauvre le plus démunis c'est
vraiment devenu une urgence
indépendamment du réchauffement
climatique dépendamment de deux des
questions écologiques pur il faut
vraiment se retrousser les manches et se
mettre à travailler pour un monde
meilleur tous ensemble c'est un thème
qui est très lié à l'actualité vous
qu'il ya la cow boys ça se déroulait
bientôt c'est une volonté également
c'est quelque chose que vous voulez
pousser aussi vous de votre côté
alors nous ce que nous espérons c'est
qu'à la suite de ces trois séances les
chrétiens localement ici sur saint
quentin et même peut-être sur le diocèse
vont s'engager dans des actions les
actions que nous propose le pape
d'ailleurs il ne fait pas que faire un
constat il nous dit aussi engager vous
voici des actions que vous pouvez
commencer à faire pour que le monde que
notre terre commune comme que notre
maison commune
d'ailleurs c'est une expression qui a
été souvent reprises par les médias que
notre maison commune soit plus belle
dorénavant c'est c'est finalement un
appel aussi à tous les habitants de la
terre tous les citoyens puisque aux
chrétiens en particulier complètement
cette encyclique elle était très très
attendue d'un certain nombre je dirais
de de gens engagés sur le problème du
climat et de la justice et elle vient à
point nommé pour effectivement tenté de
d'aidé à la prise de conscience qui les
ya là un enjeu énorme sur cette 21e
conférence des parties pour qu'enfin on
débouche sur des résultats
nécessairement contraignant pour
effectivement faire en sorte que au delà
des aspects techniques en dessous on
soit dans en mesure de ne pas dégrader
de façon irréversible cette maison
commune dont on vient de parler
justement dans cette encyclique il ya
peut-être fin
- qui français c'est un plein de mots
mais il y avait aussi des choses un peu
concrètes pour justement les christian
pour tous les citoyens qui veulent
justement s'en inspirer absolument
il ya des choses concrètes alors
peut-être pas dans l'acte quotidien
quoique nous dit aussi que l'on peut
changer dans notre façon de voir le
monde
si vous voulez il nous propose d'avoir
un nouveau regard un regard total sur le
monde c'est à dire pas seulement sur les
objets inanimés sur aussi tout le tout
tous les les pauvres tous les gens qui
ont souffert d'un déploiement de
richesse trop important on a oublié la
terre et on a oublié les plus pauvres on
a oublié les plus démunis donc on peut
changer dans notre quotidien et ils nous
demandent aussi avec courage nous mêmes
de d'interpeller nos politiques
d'interpeller la de rentrer dans la
société civile pour faire bouger les
choses c'est le message que vous voulez
prolonger avec justement à ces trois
conférences débats qui vont être
organisées en fait on veut qu'on veut
mieux faire comprendre le message du
pape
à travers ces trois séances et trois
séances et on voudrait qu'après les gens
nous disent et maintenant et nous sommes
en train de préparer et maintenant juste
après les trois conférences cc3
confiance et pour mieux aider à
appréhender justement ces problématiques
mais ce que certains jeunes qui seraient
peut-être recherche voilà de d'actes
concrets à accomplir vont ainsi
retrouver justement si oui il ya
plusieurs niveaux de là dedans dans
l'action il ya effectivement des actes
très concret je vais prendre un vin qui
vous paraîtra peut être pas très concret
mais par exemple d investir d investir
la recherche sur les énergies fossiles
si aujourd'hui il ya des fortunes qui
sont appliqués à la recherche de
nouvelles ressources de 2,2
de pétrole par exemple eh bien si ces
sommes là était investi pour chercher
des énergies alternatives et bien d'une
pierre onfray de coûts et à ce titre là
le ccfd vient de créer un fonds de
placement free fossiles free c'est à
dire sans aucune com comme il a créé un
fonds de placement en évitant de placer
de l'argent d'entreprises qui font de
l'armement par exemple ou qui sont dans
les paradis fiscaux est bien le fossile
free est une démarche que tout citoyen
peut faire il suffit d'aller voir sa
banque et en disant mais voilà j'ai un
petit peu d'argent à placer pour pour
mes vieux jours pour mes enfants etc
ou est ce que vous le passez donc c'est
vraiment une réflexion profonde et
globale dans cette encyclique justement
c'est grâce à la personnalité du pape
qu'on soit vraiment ce nouveau papa
changer quelque chose parce que ça a
créé un engouement vous le ressentez
peut-être dans votre paroisse bon ce
qu'il faut c'est quand même il faut
quand même reconnaître que l'église se
préoccupe de la notion de
l'environnement depuis longtemps depuis
jean paul ii et même peut-être depuis le
xiiie siècle bon mais le ce cas ce qui
est nouveau dans cette encyclique c'est
qu'elle a un langage très simple et ça
c'est du fait du yo-yo françois c'est
vraiment il instaurer vous sentez assez
un chargement
il ya ça et le fait aussi qu'il ait
travaillé avec avec d'autres
d'autres courants chrétiens pour
préparer cette en est cette encyclique
qui les utilisent et des réflexions de
dupes bartholomé par exemple donc je
pense que le pape l'a s'adresse comme
vous le voyez dans les adresses d'homme
à homme
en fait à tous les hommes de bonne
volonté pour leur dire ça suffit on est
en train d'épuiser la planète
les pauvres sont de plus en plus pauvres
faites quelque chose et vous tous chacun
d'entre vous pouvez faire quelque chose
parce que c'est quand même une
personnalité forte
est ce qu'il ya des vitesses jusqu'à des
gens qui retournent vers vers le
christianisme parce que justement à
cause de ce pas parce qu'ils sont un peu
galvanisé sylla comme a galéré les
colombiens l'espérons moi je crois que
françois et ait d'abord un homme qui
écoute qui coûte quitte une qualité
assez rare aujourd'hui puisque chacun a
sa vérité assénée donc c'est un homme
qui écoute beaucoup et puis surtout il
et il remet effectivement ce que de
christine 10 à l'instant il se remet au
centre du message message chrétien à
savoir que les pauvres sont le coeur de
la foi chrétienne et qui j'allais dire
pour paraphraser quelqu'un d'autre qui
pourrait penser être chrétien sans avoir
le souci des pauvres de fait ne naît pas
chrétien c'est ça c'est ça qui dit et
c'est exactement ce message qui dit ce
message là étaient entendus alors je
dirai juste une chose qui est juste une
phrase il dit par exemple que les
limites maximales d'exploitation de la
planète sont déjà dépassés et nous
n'avons pas encore résolu le problème de
l'homme de la pauvreté voilà donc c'est
ça qu'il identifie ce lien fort entre un
comportement à ses prédateurs des hommes
entre eux et des hommes vis-à-vis des
ressources et de l'accaparement des
ressources pour une minorité alors que
alors que beaucoup manquent encore du
nécessaire et il dit là c'est pas
possible de continuer comme ça il a il
est entendu
c'est un pape moderne on peut dire gens
qui nous fait réagir à quelque chose est
ce que le pape françois a annoncé qu'il
allait sortir un album pop rock et c'est
pas une blague vous propose d'en écouter
un extrait
why can speak aux responsables oui c'est
l'orgueil ou détesté yeux de biche et
l'année nantua la dépêche détection à
des séances offertes aux services pros
de total alors le pape n'est pas allé en
studio pour enregistrer cet album c'est
un album qui reprend des extraits de ses
discours sur fond de rock progressif qui
s'appelle wake up
il complète voix des extraits de son
discours les plus émouvants donné lors
de ces divers voyages à travers le monde
entre 2013 et 2015 c'est comme un
nouveau moyen de communiquer c'est très
moderne
on peut le dire tout à fait d'ailleurs
vous avez remarqué je crois je crois
avoir entendu que ils ont utilisé toutes
les langues
donc voilà l'universalisme et puis
pourquoi mais franchement pourquoi pas
faut tourner cette scène montre et c'est
une bonne chose aussi
moi je crois enfin je suis pas je
connais le rap
voilà et je trouve que le rap a par
exemple est une culture qui permet de
lire des choses alors why not mais bien
je le rappelle il y aura trois soirées
conférences débats donc une première
octobre une le 8 octobre et une le 15
octobre hall 15 octobre pardon à 20h45
donc sur trois thèmes différents
écologie et fois approche globale en
s'appuyant sur l'encyclique l'écologie
lui à travers le prisme de l'économie
ses conséquences sur l'environnement et
sur l'homme et l'écologie l'homme la
pauvreté qui peut résulter du non
respect de l'environnement
le lieu c'est l'église saint pierre
dulac 56 avenue joseph kessel à montigny
le bretonneux et nous restons justement
sur le thème de la religion pour la
première fois à montigny-le-bretonneux
la messe a été célébrée en arabe samedi
dernier une cinquantaine de familles de
chrétiens d'orient réfugier dans les
yvelines se sont rendus à l'église
saint-pierre du lac
l'actualité récente autour des migrants
et des chrétiens d'orient a incité les
responsables du diocèse instauré cet
office pour leur offrir une messe dans
leur langue
et selon leur état regardez ce reportage
de mélanie poté
une première au diocèse des yvelines
samedi dernier à montigny le bretonneux
la messe était célébrée en arabe dans
l'assistance des syriens irakiens et
libanais réfugié en france et pour eux
cela faisait des mois qui n'avait pas
participé à un office dans leur langue
c'est très important pour nous de prix
en arabe nous sommes en paix on peut
vraiment se libérer et privés à l'autre
façon hyper c'est notre longue
aujourd'hui je suis dans une chorale
je chante en français on n'a pas ça dans
notre pays c'est plus important la
liberté un pays qu'ils ont dû fuir il ya
plusieurs mois à cause de leur foi
l'importance de la communauté des
chrétiens d'orient qui s'agrandit avec
l'accueil récent de réfugiés incité les
responsables du diocèse a organisé cette
messe dorénavant il y aura une messe
tous les mois en arabe à saint-quentin
de manière à permettre que ces chrétiens
qui arrive ne subissent pas la double
peine après celle d'avoir été chassés de
chez eux de devoir en plus perdre leurs
racines leur culture notre souci c'est
de leur offrir la possibilité d'être
accueilli dans leur langue dans leur
culture avec leur manière de prier
certainement le message du pape a eu un
impact sur l'ensemble des paroisses du
monde et je trouve que la réponse des
chrétiens ce que j'en entends ce que
j'envoie est une réponse très ouverte et
en même temps très responsable une
responsabilité qui passe par
l'accompagnement dans les procédures
administratives et dans la vie de tous
les jours
pour cette première messe selon le rite
maronite 250 personnes étaient présentes
un moment qu'ils ont pu apprécier
ensemble autour de leur religion
le prochain office fin le 10 octobre en
l'église saint-martin pouvait justement
alors une réaction par rapport à cette
messe c'était un devoir justement de de
l'organiser c'était un devoir de léguer
diocèse je pense je suis très fier que
le diocèse et penser à l'organiser et je
n'étais pas malheureusement mais quand
je vois les les visages et des sourires
des gens qui ont pu avoir une messe dans
leur langue
après de nombreuses de nombreux mois de
difficultés merci qui je pense que c'est
un réconfort c'est aussi retrouver une
communauté donnée la communauté des
chrétiens et donc je pense que c'est
l'accueil parfait elle a commises et les
chrétiens justement doit peut-être et
défunt doit forcément et des cetc ces
migrants elle se doit vraiment d'agir
pour je crois que 20 kg par également je
crois que ce qui vient d'être dit c'est
que ces gens là ont tout perdu il
faudrait qu effectivement il ne perd pas
aussi leur culture et je crois que j'en
fais partie merci beaucoup à vous d'être
venu en plateau merci à vous merci et à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout le monde
ou presque connaît le technocentre de
renault situé à guyancourt mais aviez
sans frédéric se trouve un autre centre
de recherche de la marque un peu moins
célèbre celui ci ils concernent
principalement les véhicules utilitaires
et fête cette année ses 50 ans un
reportage de mélanie côté les fourgons
les fourgonnettes des véhicules
historiques de l'entreprise renault
passe par ce centre situé à villiers
saint frédéric depuis 50 ans villiers
saint frédéric
reste quand même
le spécialiste a les dires du véhicule
utilitaire donc les compétences sont
vraiment ici développement tout ce qui
concerne les véhicules électriques et
véhicules utilitaires pardon démarre ici
contrairement à au technocentre là on
est vraiment dans le fief du véhicule de
véhicules particuliers installé en 1965
le centre se spécialise sur les
véhicules utilitaires des véhicules
destinés aux professionnels à partir de
ici on fait tous les essais qui sont
nécessaires à valider un véhicule en
cours de véhicules utilitaires en cours
de conception de développement c'est à
dire de la fiabilité durabilité des
essais de liaison au sol de la
préparation pour des essais de thermique
de l'acoustique et puis de l'étanchéité
de l'ingénierie au banc d'essai ce sont
1200 personnes qui travaillent sur les
véhicules économie à présent nous vous
en parlions la semaine dernière vendredi
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles évident non organisé pour la
deuxième année consécutive les smart des
entreprises et collectivités se sont
rassemblés au campus dash c'est autour
de tables rondes et d'ateliers et pour
parler de l'économie circulaire ce
concept économique s'inscrit dans le
cadre du développement durable
son objectif est de produire des biens
et des services tout en limitant le
gaspillage des matières premières et de
l'énergie un reportage de fanny bourdon
ce vendredi au campus d'acheter à jouy
en josas entreprises et collectivités
ont participé aux smart days ce rendez
vous désormais annuel organisé par la
cci versailles yvelines aborde chaque
année une évolution technologique
les objets connectés en 2014 l'économie
circulaire pour cette année gérard
bachelet qui est à l'initiative de cet
événement nous en donne une définition
ce qui est important c'est tout
simplement que l'on puisse réutiliser
les déchets
des entreprises pour en faire de
nouveaux produits je crois que c'est la
save la plus simple définition
d'économie circulaire c'est à dire qu'on
évite d'utiliser les ressources
2 les ressources qui diminue de plus en
plus et l'énergie qui me plaisent en
plus pour justement pouvoir utiliser les
déchets et les ré exploiter dans de
nouveaux produits
tables rondes et ateliers ont permis aux
acteurs de la région de mieux
appréhender ce nouveau concept
d'économie aux nombreux enjeux
je pense que c'est d'ouvrir
sur la nouvelle économie sont l'économie
du nouveau monde c'est à dire une
économie qui est une économie de
fonctionnalité une économie circulaire
une économie de partager une économie
qui marie les grandes les deux grandes
transformations de ce siècle
c'est dire les questions digital et
environnemental si la transition
technologique a pu détruire des emplois
l'économie circulaire ancrée 3700
entreprises travaillent dans ce secteur
ce qui représente plus de 600 mille
emplois en france et maintenant comme
chaque lundi vous avez rendez vous avec
votre chronique culture après avoir
annoncé la saison artistique du théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
présenter le festival île de france
sephora a la manie vient nous parler du
concert de christophe cha sol bonsoir
fait fort
bonsoir florane dont vendredi dernier se
produisait au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
christophe cha seul dans le cadre du
festival île de france comme vous le
disiez très justement alors qui est
christophe chasseurs utile christophe
cha seul c'est un pianiste compositeur
arrangeur d'origine martiniquaise né en
1976 il rentre au conservatoire de
musique à l'âge de 4 ans où ils
consacrent consacrera 16 ans avant de
rejoindre le berklee college of music de
boston
depuis il compose pour le cinéma la
télévision et la publicité
il a également travaillé pour le groupe
phoenix et sébastien tellier à partir de
chasseuil se met à composer des albums
avec son amie laurence clés à la
batterie sa spécificité mais les leçons
l'image et la musique avec une suite
d'accords pour offrir un spectacle en 3d
on l'a rencontré il nous en part
naturellement voilà j'ai mêlé les deux
médiums parce que c'était une évidence
pour moi j'adore la synchronicité
j'adore là
west side story par exemple où chaque
geste est un mythe au musée a mis en
musique et je trouve magique de voir de
voir la musique à l'écran là je fabrique
la musique avec la vidéo avec les sons
de la vidéo donc voilà j'ai c'est ça me
donne un objet un peu totale quoi alors
son concert actuel propose des morceaux
de son dernier album big sun sorti dans
les bacs en mars 2015 album dans lequel
chat sol vous les relier en 3d le créole
le son des oiseaux les odeurs les
sensations les images du carnaval de la
martinique son île natale
c'est le dernier album d'une trilogie
baptisé ultra score l'ultra skull
pourchasse holtz et la production d'un
visuel et d'un sonore unique à partir de
fragments du réel
m
et pour créer ces ultras score chasseuil
s'inspire de musique de rue de musiques
d'ailleurs au travers de voyage pour
nous plonger dans l'atmosphère d'un pays
et dans l'esprit de ceux qui l'habitent
ou le traverse avec toujours cette
volonté d'harmoniser le monde et la
musique et la vie quand il me dit ça tu
as honte à disposition un arsenal de
choses qui font du son dont les
instruments par exemple ou talent et tu
peux faire des gammes des riffs dépit du
sortes de choses qui font des qui font
qu'il faut la musique
et puis au bout d'un moment battu dit
tiens ça je l'aï déjà fait tiens
j'aimerais bien trouver autre part un
truc qui fait du son et voilà que plus
tu regardes tu écoutes autour de toi ce
qui se passe et c'est très naturel de
faire ça alors musique de rue sonorités
d'ailleurs jazz est ce qu'on peut
rattacher christophe cha seul un joueur
particulier sephora alors effectivement
les influences musicales sont très
éclectiques et christophe cha seules
deux formations classiques se définit
comme le stravinsky ou le ravel debussy
contemporain il puise son inspiration
dans le courant impressionniste du xxème
siècle pour ces accords un courant
caractérisée par une écriture dans le
temps non pas linéaire mais au contraire
fait d'une succession d'impression mon
côté ça donne envie reste il ya des
prochaines dates de concert pour un
contrat on voit alors prochains concerts
prévus en ile de france le 13 novembre à
enghien les bains puis s'en suivra une
tournée mondiale pour chats sol le japon
la belgique prévue pour revenir à paris
le 24 mai prochain pour le festival de
jazz vous retrouverez toutes les dates
de sa tournée sur son site ww point chat
seul point fr eh bien merci à sephora on
vous retrouve mercredi à 18h30 dans
kiosque pour parler culture et
maintenant un mot de versailles l'oeuvre
d'anish kapoor a été vandalisée pour la
quatrième fois nouvelles dégradations
ont été commises dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi sur le vagin de la
reine la sculpture installée dans le
parc du château vers minuit un ou
plusieurs inconnus ont inscrit le mot
blâme sur une des feuilles d'or masquant
les inscriptions antisémites qui avaient
étaient inscrits lors de la nuit du sein
au 6 septembre sur d'ortie corner et
autres déboires peut-être pour le
château de versailles ce n'est pas
encore avérée mais la série verseille de
canal+ menace de quitter la france
elle réclame une revalorisation de
crédit d'impôt audiovisuelle la série
pourrait ainsi être tourné en belgique
pour des raisons budgétaires
les nouvelles incitations fiscales
pourrait permettre aux producteurs
d'obtenir une aide minimum de 7 millions
d'euros sur un budget de 30 millions
d'euros
la série versailles a mis cinq ans à
voir le jour et veut se projeter à
l'international
une première partie du tournage s'est
déjà déroulée entre versailles saut et
bry sur marne et enfin un mot de sport
pour clôturer ce journal on tennis le
tournoi international futur de plaisir
s'est clôturée ce week-end par la très
belle victoire nationale du belge maxime
authom tête de série numéro 1 contre le
surprenant album j'ai allemand jérémy
jahn pour ce tournoi une nouvelle
technologie a été lancée la société mojo
à installer et tester pendant les quinze
jours de compétition un système de
replay qui analyse en temps réel les
statistiques des joueurs
l'innovation permet également aux
téléspectateurs de revenir sur les
moments clés de la rencontre et de
revoir les points
on écoute tout de suite le cofondateur
de l'entreprise emmanuel vie de vote aux
jo il était au micro dé michael et demi
d'euros et de camille lambert alors
c'est vraiment que avec une vidéo
donc en fait c'est une caméra qu'on met
sur un court et l'algorithme il a misé
tout ce qui sort de la caméra et il est
capable de vraiment comprendre tout ce
qui se passe dans le match juste en
analysant image par image ce qui se
passe donc du coup on comprend qu'ils
aient un joueur ou et la balle où elle
terrain et du coup il est capable de
dire bon ben là c'est un service cela
c'est un retour la balle rebondit ici
etc etc
et c'est à partir de ça qui va calculer
toutes les stades que vous voyez là
alors ce dispositif coûte 3000 euros et
si les tests sont concluants le système
pourrait être utilisé par france
télévisions pendant le tournoi de roland
garros dans les années à venir
c'est maintenant la fin de cette édition
tout de suite vous restez avec nous vous
retrouver m michael elle me d'euros pour
le cpie sports au programme résultat du
match de la coupe de france de ce
week-end
reprise du championnat de basket la
revancharde mais aussi les all-blacks
cmt à ne pas manquer pour ma part je
vous retrouve demain dès 18 heures pour
une nouvelle édition du journal
direct je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée